Hello Diablo community, welcome to another Diablo 4 Campfire Chat.
This is our PTR Campfire Chat for Season 8.
My name is Adam Fletcher, I'm the Director of Community here.
Of course I'm joined by this panel.
A lot of familiar faces, do you guys want to introduce yourself?
Hi, I'm Colin Feiner, I'm a Design Director on Diablo 4.
Hey, I'm Derek Nunez, I'm a Lead Seasons Designer here on Diablo 4.
And hi, I'm Charles Dunn, I'm a Class Designer working on the Final Design team.
Awesome, and we're also joined by Ruben, Ruben Marquez, aka Bloodshed.
He's actually behind the scenes, he'll be playing through some gameplay that we're going to be showing off here.
Hello.
Oh, there he is, he's saying hi, waving.
We'll see more of him here in a little bit with, maybe not Marak, Stan anymore.
We got to see a good minute and a half of him before the stream actually started.
Crazy day.
First, I do want to start off with that we had a smoothie delivery this morning, and Marcus is not here.
As you can see, I'm here hosting this because he forgot my smoothie in the order.
So I just kicked him off the stream.
No, I'm just kidding.
But I told him I'd bring it up because I'm like, oh, my smoothie's not here.
But either way, we have a lot to talk about regarding Season 8.
And that's actually the end of the stream, so that's all I wanted to bring up.
Thank you.
No, we have a lot to talk about for Season 8 PTR, but I know a few other topics that we wanted to hit on
was kind of related to some of the quality of life stuff that's going to be coming with this specific season
based off of feedback and things we've seen within the game.
And also one big topic is around mid-season updates.
It's actually something that a lot of people have been asking about.
And we do want to give a little bit of an update on what mid-season updates will be going forward
and how we're kind of thinking about it from here.
So, Colin, did you want to talk a little bit about how we're planning on doing mid-season updates?
Yeah, I think first it's helpful to sort of talk about the history of the mid-season balance patch.
Originally, when we had talked about mid-season, it was pretty early in the lifecycle of Diablo 4.
We would add a ton of items and we do sort of envision doing a lot of big swings
in terms of big nerfs to overperforming builds and big buffs to underperforming builds.
But as we've seen, as we've added more progression and things like Season 4 itemization,
there's a lot more time investment in terms of getting your build online and really refining and optimizing it.
And what we found is when you put so much time into your character, it feels really bad when we nerf things, right?
So, Season 6 is a great example where you might have done so much work to temper your gear
and masterwork your gear and level up those paragons that we were really hesitant to do
like a big nerf swing as part of the mid-season balance patch.
Sort of on the other hand, right, we didn't want to massively buff underperforming builds
to match the overperforming builds because we didn't want to create this insane, you know,
sort of arms race and then we're at pit tier 9000, right?
It'd be ridiculous.
So what we ended up doing was actually kind of like anemic number of tweaks.
Like they weren't really necessarily making a big impact.
And we took a step back and sort of asked ourselves like, well, what are we actually getting out of this?
What are you, the players, actually getting out of this?
And I think we're at a sort of point where we want to pivot and adjust our philosophy a little bit.
And I think we've already seen some of this philosophy come to life in Season 7.
Yeah, exactly.
I know, especially in the beginning of the season, people probably saw us make some tweaks
in the first couple of weeks related to some really crazy numbers that maybe they weren't even numbers
in some of the stuff that people saw in the start of the actual season.
Yeah.
So all that is to say, I think really what we're going to start taking a look at is not doing massive swings in the midseason,
but instead focusing our efforts on the launch of a season.
So we're going to take that time and we're going to make sure that like there's a much higher quality launch release
and taking a lot of that balance time and making sure that when we do launch a season, it's higher quality, right?
We want the pit tier disparities to be a little bit lower.
We want to make sure that, you know, when a new season launches, the new builds that we're adding are going to be really effective
and there's a lot of new fun ways to play.
This doesn't mean we're never going to balance or touch the game.
It actually means we're just going to shift our efforts to the beginning of the season.
So early on, we're going to be pretty vigilant in terms of things that are underperforming or way overperforming
and acting quickly on them.
Yeah.
The goal here is really to get everything closer in terms of like just like less egregious, you know, builds being super, super high up there.
We saw that, I think, specifically in like season six with like the spirit born and it kind of stayed consistent that way.
We know we got a lot of feedback of like, hey, this feels kind of poopy if, you know, my build is like, you know, 30, 40 pit tiers below.
And so the goal is really to kind of bring and keep things more aligned, especially at the start of the season.
So as Colin mentioned, in the first couple of weeks, I know there's going to be more effort in putting tweaks during that time to really respect the player's time as well.
Yeah.
Oh, go ahead.
The timing is really important because like our mid-season updates in the past had come a month or a month and a half into the season once players have been really invested in their build.
And now we're going to be much more focused on rapid updates, you know, within a week or two after the season launch to make sure that if we are making those adjustments, it's at a point where, hey, you're not, you know, you're not complete with the season.
You're not done yet.
And you can adjust and you can, you know, make sure that your time is respected in that way.
Definitely.
So to really clarify, you know, when the season launches, I'll use Bloodwave as an example.
That was something we saw pretty early on and it was way too overtuned, right?
Like you didn't even really have to invest in your character to get to a point where you're godlike.
And that is something that we would probably act quickly on as a part of the next season, for example.
And I think like a big point of clarity is like Bloodwave using that as an example is very much an S tier build right now in this season.
S plus.
Yeah, S plus for sure.
I think that the goal is not to immediately take it to F or even immediately take it to C or anything like that.
It's really keep it still an S but like also make sure that it's still like at least lined up with like the other builds that might be up there in that top tier.
Yeah.
Conversely too, I just want to make it super clear.
If we see things that we added that are new, for example, if the seasonal powers aren't performing in a way that feels really powerful and crunchy, we're going to be buffing those.
So it's not only looking out for the S plus, it's also looking for the things that missed the mark.
So we're going to be buffing those also.
Awesome.
Yeah.
So I know that players at the start of season eight will see us be a lot more reactionary towards those first couple weeks in the early part of that season.
So yeah, just wanted to clarify that with players because we've seen a lot of questions about mid-season updates.
Is this a mid-season update when they see a patch or something like that?
And so going forward, I know that's going to be the plan as we look at updating the game in the future.
And if you hide things early, I will Liam Nees in your ass.
I will know.
There you go.
We heard it first.
Colin's just waiting behind you.
That's what he does.
In the closet.
Yeah.
Like the little demon kid right behind you.
Exactly.
The other thing that we want to talk about is kind of like state of the game, especially with season seven, where we're at and kind of how we're looking at that towards season eight.
I think one of the biggest points of feedback we've heard related to season seven is kind of the pace of the game.
Yeah.
You know, sometimes you blink and you're level 20 and you're like, holy crap, what happened?
So I know you wanted to talk a little bit more about that as well.
Yeah, absolutely.
So just sort of our perspective on season seven has been the progression is very fast, way faster than we sort of expected.
Part of it is a lot of the really cool new seasonal powers.
Part of it's the head hunts being super lucrative and awesome.
And part of it's also just like the seasonal journey and the reputation board.
There's a lot of different ways to get a ton of power in Diablo 4.
And what we've seen is compared to season six, which had a lot of positive feedback as part of our rebound progression model,
is that a lot of that has sort of gone down the drain in terms of how fast players are chewing through some of the content.
So we actually have a graph that we could look at.
I apologize.
This is terrible.
But I just pulled it from the stat, our sort of stat page.
It's not the greatest.
But this is a picture of season six.
You can see on the Y-axis here.
It was taking roughly people around 15 to 17 hours on average to get to max level.
We felt like that was a pretty good journey, right?
Part of Diablo is that sort of zero to hero journey.
And part of what's fun about leveling is you start to sort of form a build and find a lot of different pieces early on
when you're still forming your character where customization is really fun, right?
You're not necessarily locked into a build.
So we felt like that was a pretty good clip for hitting max level.
It's on average, right?
So you could either go faster or slower depending on sort of how much of a blaster you are.
So we felt like that was a pretty good average, especially with difficulty tiers and your ability to sort of go faster or slower based on your pacing.
And let's go to season seven now.
And it nearly doubled.
So you can see that it was taking about nine hours on average, which is kind of insane, right?
Again, this is the average.
So if you're, you know, if you're like a Wodijo of the world, it's probably more like two hours or like 30 minutes.
And that was something that we definitely feel like has sort of missed the mark in terms of that initial journey.
So we are going to be making some changes just to adjust for a lot of the seasonal power and things like that.
We're not going to necessarily nerf the power of the seasonal power.
We still want you to feel powerful.
But we are going to essentially take a look at the one to 25 experience and just smooth that out a little bit,
which is going to essentially make the leveling experience a little bit closer to season six.
So it is going to be a slower from one to 25.
But one thing we've done to sort of compensate that is we've taken a look at the itemization.
We don't like that rares and sort of magic items immediately disappear after the first five minutes of the game.
Yeah, I think you kind of get to that point.
Like we were talking about if you get to like level 20, you blink and you're level 20.
And then at the same time you blink and you're like, oh, blues and yellows.
Like, I only look at oranges now.
Or like, what's this other color?
So I know that we have some changes that you wanted to talk about.
Yeah, and again, like a lot of this is in the spirit of making sure that zero to hero journey is really satisfying, right?
That's what makes it so awesome when playing Diablo is that sort of I start with nothing and become a god, right?
So we are taking a look at the itemization so that it doesn't just feel like a slog from one to 25.
What we're going to be doing is, oh, you know what?
I'm going to jump actually into the legendaries really quick because it's really important, a really important part of this.
The other thing that was contributing to this leveling sort of pace was that players are getting a legendary every three to four minutes.
And that's from one to 60.
That's not just in the end game.
And it just felt like legendary item quality was just too prevalent across the leveling journey.
You didn't have, you sort of hit max level.
There was no journey to assembling your build.
You just had everything as part of the codex of power.
So we're also reducing the legendary rate from leveling.
We're not really touching the end game legendary drop rates, but from leveling we are adjusting that.
And to compensate that, to jump back into the magic and rares.
We're making it so that magics can have up to two affixes.
So sometimes you're going to find, you know, from your one to 25 journey a pretty good magic item.
It might actually be better than a rare, for example, because it might have dropped earlier for you.
It might have higher eye power.
And then we're also making it so that rares can sometimes have up to three affixes.
And what that means is, you know, when you get a drop at level 35 from a whisper cache, right now, you know, in Season 7 it feels terrible when you don't get a legendary item.
Because you just know that it's just not even worth looking at, right?
But now that rare items can have up to three affixes, that means that you might have a really good imprintable base.
It means all the rares that drop across the game from 1 to 60 could actually be pretty great gear for you.
Especially with all of our crafting options.
So we think that this helps smooth out the 1 to 60 journey.
I will caveat that the rare quality is not the best at max level still.
It's going to be a lower eye power, so you're not going to have to filter through a bunch of rares at max level.
We're not going to go back to pre-season 4.
So, yeah, we think this is this sort of smoothing out of the leveling curve, taking a look at the magic rarities or the item qualities,
is just going to make the experience feel a lot more rewarding and satisfying as you go through these levels.
And then I know some of the other items we've been talking about have been a little bit of that torment progression.
We've seen drastic differences between Season 6 to Season 7, and it's something I know we're making tweaks to.
Yeah, so the other half of Diablo is obviously the max level endgame, right?
And we've heard a ton of feedback that it just feels like a weak endgame right now.
You can just blast through all the torment tiers.
There's nothing that's really satisfying about it.
There's nothing to work towards just because you're just getting so much power so frequently and just really crushing this content.
So what we've done here is, if we go to the slide, we've actually given...
Actually, let me jump into some of the stats here because I think it's really interesting.
A lot of people got to Torment 4 very quickly.
So on average, it was taking players around 15 hours to get to Torment 4.
That's roughly double how quickly it took in Season 6, which is kind of insane.
Again, it's the culmination of Seasonal Powers and all this crazy stuff going on.
And the other part of it is that 50% of players are actually hitting Torment 4.
And just from a philosophy standpoint, we really want whatever the hardest Torment tier is, in this case Torment 4, to be aspirational.
And to us, that means around 10%.
That means that, you know, if you're really Johnny Badass, you know, you need to be in the top 10% of players to actually get there.
And it's not hitting the mark.
So what we're going to do is make some adjustments.
So Torment 1 is now going to start at Pit Tier 10, which means we've effectively added 10 Pit Tiers to the Pit because now Torment 1 starts earlier.
And then we've also increased the Torment Pit Scaling health by roughly 20% multiplicative and then some damage increases.
Yeah, and that Pit Scaling is, every level of a Pit is multiplicative on previous levels.
So it's not just like, oh, whatever Pit I was at, it's now 20% harder.
It's actually like kind of stacking 20% every level.
So the end result is that, you know, a Pit Tier 100 is much harder than it was before.
And that will, that makes it, you know, harder to reach that absolute highest end.
And it gives you a little bit more for those builds and those Blasters who are getting up to that highest Pit Tier.
There's going to be, it's going to be quite a bit harder to get to quite that same level next season.
Yeah, absolutely.
So with that, sort of culminates in moving Torment 1 to Pit Tier 10 and effectively adding 10 Pit Tiers
and increasing the multiplicative scaling of the Pit Tier scaling is the journey is going to be a lot more sort of satisfying.
There's a lot more sort of peaks to climb.
And it also means Pit Tier 150 is going to be very difficult.
So, so difficult that I don't believe any of you will reach it.
I don't know, I'll do something silly on the stream.
He says this now.
I'll probably, oh, that's not enough for doing something silly on the stream.
And then like within the first stream.
That's a challenge to all of you out there.
Yeah, you all can vote on the silly thing that I do.
But conversely, I just want to cover this really quickly though.
Torment 4 isn't going to be insanely harder than it was before.
It's going to be roughly around Pit Tier 76 is on live right now.
So season 7.
So think about the game that you're playing right now.
Torment 4 is going to be about 11 Pit Tiers harder.
So it's still achievable.
It's just that upper end is also just going to be that much harder to sort of climb through.
Awesome.
So we've got a lot of changes coming for like Torment Scaling.
Obviously some itemization changes.
So the big thing being as you're leveling up, you're going to see a lot more opportunities to find items.
Especially with the changes to blue and yellow items there.
And then of course, as you mentioned, the big caveat is like at 60, the item power on Legendaries is still going to be the best method and the best items to actually grab.
So yeah, lots of big changes coming up.
Great to actually walk through all of them.
I know we have a ton more to talk about specifically around the new season.
So thank you, Colin.
We're going to jump over to Derek because I know we do want to talk about the new season and what players are actually going to be experiencing in this PTR.
Again, just to redefine what PTR is for some people because I got messages from people going like, well, PTRs are sometimes buggy.
And I'm like, well, it's a PTR.
So it is like a beta or an alpha, an early look into a game.
So we expect that.
There will be like known issues and we'll actually have those known issues on our forums.
So people can actually see them.
You can report bugs.
It actually helps when you guys actually jump into a PTR and experience it and give us feedback because that helps tweak the start of the season for the better, essentially.
But with season eight, we will be having, of course, a PTR and we'll be talking about it here in a second.
And then we'll be talking about that.
And we'll be talking about it.
But we're actually working on season seven and really amplify or celebrate or enhance it within that respective season.
So we've seen that with season four with the Helltide revamps and whatnot, as you mentioned.
Season seven was the emphasis on the Tree of Whispers and bounties.
So as Colin kind of mapped out the journey to the endgame, we wanted to shine focus on a major endgame feature, namely surrounding our bosses.
And we have a lot of really cool bosses in the world of Sanctuary, but more specifically the lair boss system, or as some of us, and we reference it to as the boss ladder.
So season eight focus is on the lair boss system.
We're going to be doing a whole mess of new things to it.
So we're adding new bosses, new mechanics, quality of life updates, and a revamped materials loop that I'm going to be covering throughout the course of this segment.
So, you know, first I just want to kind of talk about, you know, the new bosses and additions to the roster.
So when we're talking about the lair bosses, these are like the biggest, baddest, you know, bosses of Sanctuary.
So we're looking at how do we add to the roster in a meaningful way, but also which bosses do we add that are impactful and versatile enough to carry the entire theme of a season.
So with that in mind, we're just asking ourselves a question of which of the right bosses to bring.
You mentioned an old friend.
So we had to choose something that was versatile.
We had to choose something that was big, bad.
So that's where we go to Belial.
Yes, season eight, Belial's return.
Belial's back in Sanctuary.
He is climbing his way to the top of the lair boss ladder.
He is the new, you know, exalted pinnacle challenge within the ladder.
He is the highest challenge, the highest reward.
And he also has some very unique reward related tricks up his sleeve that I'll cover a little bit later.
So for now, just know that Belial's back and he's also just not joining the party alone.
He's bringing a couple of friends from our vessel of hatred.
So first up is our buddy Urvar.
So Urvar's joining the roster of the lair boss ladder system.
He's going to be filling out kind of like the lowest rung of the ladder.
So he's going to be joining the party with the Varshawns and the Beast of Nice and whatnot.
So Urvar's back and we're also bringing back another vessel of hatred.
A character, the Harbinger of Hatred.
I'm so happy for this.
Yeah, no, this one.
I love this fight.
We're going to see a little bit more of this guy in just a little bit.
But the Harbinger of Hatred will be joining kind of the second rung of the ladder with the likes of Durial and Undarial.
And one thing I just do want to stress is that both of these Vessel of Hatred bosses will dip into the shared loot pools of other bosses within their respective tier.
But also have some additional bonuses that is specific to the Vessel of Hatred like being a great source of tributes and runes.
But Belial, for all intents and purposes, is available to everyone and he is just the new pinnacle challenge of the boss ladder.
So you're saying even harder than Durial and Undarial right now.
He's going to be harder, more rewarding than even those.
Absolutely.
Yes.
New top tier.
Belial, Lord of Lies, he does not mess around.
And I'm really excited about this because I think this is going to pair really well with the sort of leveling journey and the torment progression where we're making things a little bit more aspirational, a little bit more challenging.
It's really like a return to the heart of the Diablo experience, right?
Sort of leveling from nothing and taking on these huge big bads to claim their loot.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think that's kind of like the inherent cool thing about the Lair Boss ladder system is that you start with like the initiate level floor.
You take those on, you graduate to the next level.
And then now you have kind of Belial just always there looming over you as kind of the aspirational, yes, I get to go fight him now.
But for those who know about our buddy Belial, Lord of Lies, you know that he kind of appears in different forms.
So this is what we're kind of referencing as like his supreme form that appears at the top of the Lair Boss ladder.
But he also has his, I guess, smaller, more agile, compact form.
I like to affectionately refer to him as baby Belial, but this is Belial in his more compact form.
And throughout the course of the season, or I guess just the Lair Boss mechanics, he's going to be popping up all over the place.
But I'm really excited about this version of Belial's new role in the Lair Boss ladder system in the sense that defeating and looting any of the Lair Bosses has a small percent chance to initiate a surprise ambush from Belial himself.
And this is really cool because this is kind of like a two for the price of one payout.
So let's say I fight Andario, I defeat Andario, I loot Andario, and I get this special ambush triggered.
And if I defeat Belial, I'll get a double payout of Andario's loot.
So I got the loot from Andario, and I get another payout of Andario's loot from defeating Belial himself.
So it's a really exciting kind of just like injection of some fun novel mechanics within the Lair Boss system that we're doing over and over and over again.
So again, really excited about this update.
And again, in the spirit of teasing kind of the rewards relationship and connection that Belial has,
this version of Belial has a very special connection to his larger supreme form in the Lair Boss ladder that I'll touch upon a little bit later.
A lot of teasing that I'm kind of just sending that.
There's a lot to go over.
We're going to lie to everybody.
Yeah.
We're just kidding.
That's the theme.
Belial's actually not here.
This is a lie.
Yeah.
So that was that.
That was the, you know, the Belial ambushes.
But I also want to talk about some additional major sweeping updates that's coming in with just the system as a whole.
And I want to talk about the summoning materials.
As we know, the way that the system currently functions is, you know, you go do activities, you get summoning items, you go visit the boss and you plop them in, you summon the boss.
And then, you know, that's kind of just a flow.
So when we're looking at the Lair Boss system, we don't just look about ways that we can add to it.
We also look about, you know, opportunities to, you know, resolve or reduce some frictions or just areas for improvement that we can have with it.
Since it's a very mature system, we get a lot of feedback that we, you know, diligently ingest and talk about and whatnot on our team.
So when it came to the summoning materials, we identified a couple of key points of, I guess, friction that players are currently having with it.
One is, since you have to ante up your summoning materials just to summon the boss, it's kind of a feels-bad moment when you realize that you just wasted, you know, X number of materials to find out that you can't defeat Durial.
Like, okay, that's a waste of materials, back to the loop, maybe I'll fight him another week or two, depending on how fast you are.
And it's just generally not a great feeling for myself or for players and whatnot.
Yeah, I definitely have run into this where it's like, I'm only going to fight the boss when I can guarantee win against it.
Right.
So you never actually fight-
And how do you know that, too, until, like, trial and error?
Like, you never really have that, like, actual fun fight with the boss where you're like, oh, am I going to lose or not?
Because it's like, well, I'm just not going to risk it.
Yeah, I've had times where I'm like, I don't know if my build's quite ready, so I'll try to fight a boss.
And then I'm like, oh, this is really tough.
Like, I die a couple times, and I'm like, do I really want to keep, like, retrying it?
Yeah.
Because, like, well, I've already invested.
I'm kind of, like, I'm kind of committed.
So with this new way, you know, I don't need to invest those right up front.
I can just go and fight them right away and see how strong I am without risking the materials.
Yeah, yeah.
So we're going to cover, like, the specificities of the new system and how it all works in a little bit.
But the other kind of pain point that we identified with the current system is also just in regards to, like, the party play.
I think my little earpiece is coming out of my ear.
There you go.
It's a common theme on this one.
The earpiece just pops out all the time.
We do it live here.
Yeah, so the other element is just the party play, right?
And as much as we want to kind of, like, entrust in our fellow man and whatnot and engage in the boss rotations and whatnot,
we have seen, you know, some areas of friction where certain players don't engage in the boss rotations
and they don't submit their materials.
Like, no one watching this stream would ever be guilty of this, but that does happen.
It's shocking, but it does happen.
Belial is on the other side of the computer.
It's like, yeah, I'll definitely pay the next rotation.
And then they leave and they take all their stuff.
So that was another kind of area of friction that we experienced with the current summoning materials.
So I think that's kind of enough of a preface just to set the tone for where the system is going now that we're introducing Season 8.
So what are we doing?
What are we?
I don't know.
Let's find out.
All right.
So Lair Keys.
So summoning materials are effectively being repurposed in their roles as a new item called Lair Keys.
And what Lair Keys do, well, I'll just start with this, is since there's no more summoning materials,
that just means that effectively all Lair bosses are free to summon.
So if you're not sure if you're ready to take on a Varshan or a Durial, just go visit them.
You know, kind of use them as a bit of a training dummy to see if you can actually, you know, take them on.
But what Lair Keys now do is they grant access to the defeated boss's horde or their treasure chest that they drop.
So now I'll just walk you through kind of the new flow.
Imagine this with me.
So you enter Durial's Lair.
You walk up to his altar and you just click the altar to summon him.
Again, no cost to you.
You fight Durial.
You defeat him.
Out pops his horde.
And now the Shards of Agony, which is now the Lair Key, you use that to open his horde and get all the oodles of loot that he went to go visit him to do.
Yeah.
And these work like Helltide chests.
So you have to pay in order to get the loot.
And the only loot comes from the person who pays.
Yeah.
That's a very important distinction is that now every member in the party needs to have the appropriate type and quantity of the Lair Keys to access the loot in the horde.
And you can still trade your keys with friends and things like that.
If you have 9999, you know, Durial mats, you can split them in half and give them to your buddies to open the chest.
Yeah, absolutely.
Sharing is caring in the system here.
And then, of course, if you're really lucky, you'll get a Belial ambush and you can get double loot.
Yeah.
Yeah, there you go.
So, again, a lot of new avenues and ways to kind of, you know, experience the system.
So we also have the Stygian Stones.
So Stygian Stones in Season 8 is living a new life now in the sense that we wanted to ensure that every boss in the first rung of the ladder,
our Initiate Lair bosses, the Varshans, Griggers, Beasts of Nice, Lord Zeres, and Urvars now,
that they're all equally relevant to getting you to climb to the next rung.
So in addition to, you can take a screenshot of this chart here.
I won't try and walk through the entire thing.
But now Stygian Stones is a drop that can drop from any of the Initiate Lair Boss tier here.
And you can crush them into your Lair Key of Choice for the second rung of the Lair Bosses.
So let's say I fight Grigger, I get a Stygian Stone, and I want to go fight Ondariel.
I can just crush that into some Ondariel keys.
And, again, just giving a little bit more flexibility in how players actually engage and progress through the Lair Boss ladder.
Again, as we know, all roads lead to Belial, Lord of Lies, you know, the top of the pinnacle of the ladder at the end.
Ooh, there's a lot.
All right, final thing here is the item bloat reduction.
So, again, with this new system, we're consolidating all the Lair Keys to one Lair Key type per boss.
So no more kind of managing two different materials.
And so I have enough material.
I have two of these, five of these.
It's just one material per boss.
We're increasing the item stacking of these to 99.
Again, to cut down on some of that bloat.
And one of my personal favorites here is that we're also normalizing the counts of required Lair Keys per, you know, boss rank.
So all the initiate tiered bosses, they require the same quantity of their respective keys.
So, too, do the graders and whatnot.
So, again, it's just cutting down on the total mental math and memory that is kind of affecting the, I guess, like, on-ramping enjoyment of the current system.
Yeah.
And Ondariel only needs one material, for example, as part of this.
Yeah, absolutely.
So you can see in this chart here, you have Pincushion Dolls, Shard of Agony, or the Stygian Stone is kind of the wild card that you can crush to any one of them.
So let's say if Ondariel needed four Pincushion Dolls, you have three of them, but you have one Stygian Stone.
You can crush that into a Pincushion Doll and go get Ondariel's Horde.
So, all right.
That was a pretty big overview and a lot of talking in charts.
But I want to take the time to, you know, throw it over to Ruben and behind the scenes here and kind of just get into just what this all looks like as part of this in-game flow.
Hello, Derek.
How are you doing, man?
I'm doing great.
How are you?
Awesome.
Yeah.
Let me open up the menu for you.
All right.
Cool.
So, in this walkthrough, I'm just going to show you kind of, or we're going to show you rather, the new flow to access the lair bosses with a little bit of a sneak peek of the Harbinger of Hatred.
So, one thing I want to just call out real quick is kind of some of the quality of life updates that we've taken to just the map presentation and the boss dungeon tooltips themselves.
And I'll kind of just go through these kind of itemized order.
So, first, all of the boss dungeon map icons have been given a little bit of a beautification treatment.
So, they're a little bit more bold, red, and easier to identify against the sea of other icons on the map.
But now I want to talk about the tooltip, and I'll just start from the top and go make my way down.
So, the first quality of life update that we added was just simply printing the name of the boss that resides within the dungeon.
You know, one of the kind of ambiguities that we had with the previous version of this system was not knowing specifically which boss lives in which dungeon.
Like, oh, who does live in the gaping crevice or who lives in the malignant tunnels?
So, now you can see here that the Harbinger of Hatred lives in the Harbinger's Den.
This is probably not the best example because who else would live in the Harbinger's Den?
Wow.
Yeah, but he technically does live in every single one of them.
He's a liar.
Yeah.
You don't know where he's at.
But yeah, so you can see here now, we print the name of the lair boss that lives in the dungeon for a little bit easier find.
Instead of the main body description, we also just give a little bit more guidance and information on, you know, what the value of defeating this boss is,
and they're directing players to the fact that they are a source of ancestral and mythic unique items.
The last two updates here are some of my favorites of this is that we also display now the required items that you need to access the lair boss's horde.
If you recall the previous, you know, iteration, that was not apparent to you,
so you would kind of like waste the time traveling to the boss just to find out that, oh, I have three or four abhorrent's hearts,
so I can't fight the boss yet.
So we wanted to, again, just smoothen out the access and onboarding to the feature.
And I think my absolute favorite update of all this is you see at the bottom,
we now have the ability to travel directly into the dungeon directly from the map.
So, again, no more teleporting to the nearest waypoint.
We just pop directly in and just get into it.
And, you know, we have Ruben loading into here, and I think this is a great time to just outline.
Outline, I've talked about the new bosses, I've talked about new mechanics,
but we have a, you know, a collection of really great existing lair bosses.
And one thing that we wanted to take as an opportunity within the season was to also enhance every other lair boss that exists within the system.
So every lair boss is getting a bit of a difficulty spike and new mechanics to, again,
freshen up the fights that we've been, you know, knowing and love.
So if you fought, you know, the Varshawns or the Durials or even the Liliths, you know, over and over and over again,
all this is in the PTR, so definitely worth checking them out again to see what's changed and, you know, how much different their experience is.
Yeah, Durial has some messed up surprises.
Yeah, Durial eats you.
Why are you spoiling it?
It's definitely worth checking out the mechanics.
But again, so this is the Harbinger of Hatred, and, you know, just as a reminder,
one thing that we do when we add a boss to the lair boss system is we don't just take the carbon copy, you know, campaign version of it.
We also take the opportunity to inject some really crazy mechanics.
So I don't necessarily want to, you know, kind of spoil the surprises of the Harbinger of Hatred's mechanics here,
but he does get pretty wild.
This is a spectacle and a half of a fight, and I'm really excited to have players check it out.
So, yeah, I think this is about all we might want to show of this guy.
Yeah, we probably won't go into it.
We don't want to spoil all the mechanics and everything,
even though we're kind of also spoiling a little bit of, like, a rogue build.
Yeah, we have a teen-eyed amongst you might have noticed some interesting things on rogue,
which I'll get to in a bit.
It's spoil or it's teasing to maintain.
Exactly.
Teasing, teasing.
Teasing everyone along here.
But, yeah, so, you know, that was a sneak peek at the Harbinger of Hatred we just talked about again,
in case you missed it, the all-lair bosses are getting a boost in both their performance
and just the mechanics that they have.
Yep.
But let's, you know, we fast-forwarded past, you know, the Harbinger of Hatred's fight,
so let's imagine a world that, you know, we fought through the whole thing, we killed him,
and let's show off now what to expect from the Horde loop flow.
So we have some footage here with this very shiny chest.
Very shiny chest.
So we have four of Horan's hearts, and now we can open up the chest.
Again, each one of us needs to have it.
And I mentioned that Belial has a chance to surprise ambush you after opening any Horde.
And here you go.
Look at this.
This is meant to be a relatively rare occurrence, but, you know, this is the magic of pre-recorded footage.
We can make the impossible happen.
And in this case, again, painting the full picture of the scenario,
you defeated the Harbinger of Hatred, you got the Horde, you opened it,
you got baby Belial, you killed him, and now you get another proc of, yeah, double the loot, double the fun.
Yeah, double the loot of what you just essentially got.
With the one-time payment of the layer keys that you deposited.
So, yeah, it really is, you know, kind of a two-for-one sale that Belial has for you.
And if you noticed, you might have seen, we did keep a bonus for party play.
So while you do have to pay to get the chest and open up the Horde,
we kept a bonus chance for loot.
So we love that people enjoy fighting the bosses as parties,
and we know that that's a fun social experience in Diablo.
So what we've done is the Hordes themselves will have bonus chances for loot when you are in a party.
And that does scale with party members.
Yep, no, absolutely.
So, yeah, a lot of loot everywhere to give.
And on the topic at the very top, I teased that Belial had a very special kind of role in the reward structure,
different from every other boss.
So defeating the ambush version of Belial is not just lucrative in the sense that it's a double payout.
He is also the sole source of the layer keys that you need to access his Supreme Form at the top of the ladder,
the Supreme Form's Horde.
So I want to show off now the Supreme Belial's very green chest here.
So you can see here, it doesn't open up right away.
I have some options.
So the really cool thing about the Supreme Belial's Horde is that you can set it to mimic the reward drops of any other existing lair boss.
So let's say if you are trying to do Durial runs to get the special stuff that he has,
and you can set your Belial to drop the Durial loot, and he will do so at an enhanced rate.
So it's even better than if you just went to go fight Durial specifically.
Yeah, so if you're really targeting Farmane and those specific uniques, you get, you know,
this version of Belial just gives you a much better chance of doing that as well.
Yep, absolutely.
And not just that in terms of, like, his value, he also guarantees one Ancestral unique drop per kill,
and he's also a really great source of the Infernal compasses.
So, you know, if you want to, you know, empower your Infernal Horde runs and whatnot,
it's never a waste of time to go visit the Belial Supreme at the top of the ladder here.
Yeah, and this is in Torment 2, and it all scales with Torment.
Exactly, yeah.
Yeah, what we're seeing in this footage is just Torment 2, so obviously, like, Torment 4,
you would get more loot out of it because it's a much more difficult challenge.
It is much more difficult.
It scales with the Torment tiers, and also if we were in a party in this example here,
we'd get even, you know, more chances of great stuff out of it as well.
That's exactly right.
All right, cool.
Well, that is the Lair Key and the Lair Boss.
I just have a lot of things to cover here.
I know we want to talk a little bit about kind of the...
It's funny because people saw it as Reuben was on the map,
because they probably saw a term, like, with apparitions and everything.
Right, yeah, there's a lot of teasing in this.
I know, a lot of teasing.
This happens when you use a live build and everything's fine.
Yeah, it's exciting.
But one thing, before we hop into the next thing,
I do want to reestablish so that everything that we just talked about
as far as what we're introducing to the Lair Boss system
and all the mechanics, new bosses and whatnot,
that is permanent.
That is just how the system works now.
So everything is getting introduced in Season 8,
but it's not leaving beyond Season 8.
It is just there.
It'll be an Eternal, so...
It will, yeah.
It'll be an Eternal.
That's just how the system works.
What the next segment, though, is
is all the Seasonal-specific stuff.
So, again, as Adam mentioned,
you might have seen some Apparition and Incursion things pop up.
So let's get into the first kind of seasonal-related content here.
Oh, the top says Lair Boss.
Okay.
Anyways, we do it live.
Apparition and Incursions.
Apparition and Incursions is a new open-world seasonal event
to empower your leveling journeys
and also kind of just spread the narrative and dramas
of Belial is back on Sanctuary
and he's spreading his own sense of, you know,
twisted realities across the land.
He's always in his efforts to try and plunge, you know,
the world of Sanctuary into his Realm of Lies
and he's doing it through this fast-paced boss rush style event
that kind of takes the spirit of, you know,
the open-world social boss play of the Blood Maiden
and making a really cool kind of just really fast-paced,
you know, bam, bam, bam, boss rush style event.
So I think we have some footage here
just to put some, yeah, some visuals to it.
So, you know, this is an area of the world
that Belial's apparitions are kind of overtaking
and throughout the course,
players are going to be defeating these apparitions
to draw out up to two of his apparition bosses.
This is pulled from a total of 10 potential apparition bosses.
So each time you go through this,
you'll fight, you know, two of them kind of randomized.
So each time should be a little bit different.
And all of this is leading up to a showdown
against Belial himself.
So again, it's celebrating bosses.
It's three bosses per event.
And the idea for this is that they're up pretty much 24-7.
So we want to just encourage that, you know,
hop on the boss train, ride it to the end,
find the next one, and just, you know,
go to your heart's content.
And, you know, celebration of bosses this season, really.
Absolutely.
And what do you get for killing those bosses?
Oh, you're going to get some cool stuff, Colin.
Let's go to the next slide.
That kind of leads us into the collectible boss powers,
seasonal powers.
Spoiled it right there.
It's already on the slide.
Yeah, we're fine.
So the theme for, the powers theme for Season 8 is boss powers.
So Belial being kind of like the illusionary character he is,
mimicry and whatnot, in Season 8,
players will be acquiring the ability to steal and mimic the powers
of up to 24 targeted bosses across Sanctuary.
So we have 24 collectible powers that are gathered
from the first time kill of targeted bosses
across the full content from level 1 till the very top.
So you asked about, you know,
what do the apparition bosses give you?
They're, aside from the loot and all that stuff,
they're also your first source of your first 10 boss powers
that make up the magic tiers.
You can kind of see in this little chart here.
Graduating from the apparition bosses,
you now go into the world bosses.
So each one of our three world bosses
have a power associated with them.
And then so too do each of our lair bosses,
capped off with Lilith with her own boss power
that you can acquire.
It's like a ladder in the boss power.
Yeah, it's definitely celebrating the progression journey
of bosses from, you know, the moment you log in
to the moment that you're powerful enough
to take down Lilith.
Belial, you know, Belial being kind of like
the star of the season.
He's special. He gets two powers
because that's just how he rolls.
Yeah, cheating.
Yeah.
And I think, you know, one of the cool things
about this kind of structure,
it's a very structured power climb.
So little ambiguity of like,
how do I get the Wandering Deaths power?
Well, go fight and kill him.
It's just that nice little structured journey
that kind of is a nice little stamp collection
just to reward each kind of a tier of progression
that you make across your, you know,
leveling and endgame journeys.
But that's not just the coolest part of it.
In my opinion here is that it's also just
how the powers work this season.
So you can see that we have four slots,
the top slot and three little kind of like supporting slots.
So the really cool thing is that each one of these powers
have two sides to them that activate
depending on which power slot you put them in.
So you can have up to one main,
one power, you can have up to one power slot
into your main power slots,
or you can have up to three power slot
into your modifier slots.
And I just want to dive into this
Wandering Deaths chest beam example here.
So if I were to slot the Wandering Deaths power
into the main power slot,
I would actually unlock the full representation
of his iconic chest beam power.
So the main powers is activating and unlocking
the actual iconic power
that is representative of the boss.
We're going to show kind of a little bit
of a showcase after this, but that's how
that respective area of the power system works.
The modifier slots though are super,
are cool and powerful in an own right though.
So let's say I don't necessarily need
the Wandering Deaths, you know,
main power for whatever utility purposes.
I can still get value out of the fact that I own it
by slotting it into the modifier slots,
which activates kind of like the side B of it,
which is more of a supporting thing.
So in this case, it's your main power.
Now it empowers your main power
to instantly execute non-boss enemies,
you know, when they're within a certain threshold of life.
So it's not just, you know,
24 ways to kind of express your, you know,
sense of power this season.
It's 48 because each of these powers have,
you know, kind of like two sides to them.
Yeah, it's really like build your own boss power.
Essentially, yeah.
It's a lot of fun just kind of like
mix-match slot around and see, you know,
what kind of a concoction you come up with.
And that's something that I'm particularly interested
in going to the PTR is like,
what are some of the favorite combinations?
Or, you know, ideally,
what are the favorite combinations
based off of the circumstance that you're going into?
Definitely.
Oh, go ahead, Charles.
One thing I wanted to,
that I'm really excited about the system
is in previous seasonal power systems,
we sometimes found as you got really high,
you know, Paragon levels,
your build is like super powerful.
The relative impact of some of the seasonal powers
was a little lower.
They didn't really scale with you
as well as we really wanted to.
We've done an update in this season
where these boss powers are going to scale
with your Paragon level as you're leveling up.
And so they actually are going to get more powerful
as you get more powerful.
So the exact number that you,
as soon as you unlock it,
it, you know, maybe is not the most powerful thing,
but as you're powering up,
it's still going to be relevant to your build
at every stage of your progression.
That's really good.
And I like the fact that the powers
don't kind of just live on their own little island.
Like they get ingrained into the other systems
that we're engaging with.
So, yeah, so that's a high level
of the boss powers for season eight.
And I want to toss it back to Ruben
for just kind of a little bit of a live showcase of them.
Hey, Derek, thanks for all that.
That was great, man.
Yeah, I'm excited.
What do you got for us?
Well, I get the fun job of showcasing
all these powers today,
but I must confess I got my smoothie,
so I'm a little jacked up today.
I'm so happy you got your smoothie.
So happy for you.
I try not to talk too fast.
I'm thrilled.
Let's go ahead and open up our inventory here.
And you'll notice on the left side,
a familiar tab is our seasonal tab,
which is boss powers.
So from this tab is where you'll be kind of interacting
with your powers throughout the season.
Like Derek mentioned,
you can drag and drop them,
equip them on the fly.
There's no penalty.
I think the team and everybody wants you
to experiment and have fun with the builds.
You can also upgrade them by hovering over them.
There's a corresponding button here on PC.
It's F.
So go ahead and push that to upgrade them.
And yeah, so the top slot is your main slot,
like Derek mentioned.
This is where your main powers go.
And all the bottom ones are your modifier slots.
So right here, you know,
Derek's favorite was the wandering death chest beam.
So as a modifier, right, you can execute enemies.
But as soon as you drag it over here,
boom, now it's a channeled ability.
And you'll notice right away, it's a prominent beam.
Yeah, it works well with channeled abilities.
It only works with channeled abilities, actually.
And it's kind of cool with densive knives
because you can adjust and do these micro adjustments
to kind of maximize the effect on your target
and just to keep it on them a little bit longer.
Yeah, and as you can kind of tell,
we're not necessarily going for subtlety
in terms of the expression of these powers this season.
I'm dying.
Someone in chat's like, Goku?
Oh, my God.
I also want to call it real quick.
Just one thing I absolutely love
is just the animations of the UI itself.
And, you know, you slot these little, like, eyeball socket,
eyeball powers into the little eye sockets,
and it blinks.
And it just is kind of just fun across the board,
just engaging with this.
Squelchers and pops.
Yeah.
So what do we got next?
The next one I want to showcase is Lilith's Wind of Hate
just because probably most of us have died to this before,
her spike ability from the ground.
And it works on almost every skill.
So you can definitely,
you can see as soon as I dash here,
I get the spikes.
With Barrage, you get the spikes.
So you can slot in almost every build
and have fun with it,
even Dance of Knives.
Really cool ability there.
Let's see what else we got.
Another fun one,
there's a transformative ability,
is Juryal's Burrow.
So it completely changes your evade skill,
and you burrow underground.
You deal damage when you go into the ground
and when you exit.
But the real cool thing is you become immune while underground,
and you can control the direction.
Oh, that's awesome.
It is awesome.
That's one of my absolute favorite.
I love that one.
You can stand still if you like or whatever,
and it scales.
As you get more evade charges,
you get more burrows.
So I'm sure there's a lot of,
especially adding three new bosses
with all kinds of crazy effects,
you can now dodge them a little bit easier,
which is great.
I'm sure there's some good use cases for that.
Yeah, and even just right there,
I want to just chime in and just say that,
you know, we showed off a power
that procs off of the evade.
We showed one that procs off channeling,
and one that procs off any skills.
One of the goals going into the design of these powers
was to just remove any ambiguity
about how do I actually proc it.
We wanted to make it as utility-focused
and straightforward as possible
so that players can really easily digest
and how they work it into their builds.
Yeah, that's a great point.
Urvar's Bombs is probably my personal favorite
as I like making builds and interesting builds.
This definitely supports ultimate builds,
and as you can see on the screen here,
it lowers your cooldown by five seconds,
which is great,
and gives you a nice damage component
to kind of top off on it.
So we're playing Rogue,
and Death Trap is an ultimate ability,
so as soon as I pop it,
you'll see Urvar's Bombs kind of shoot out,
and you get that lower cooldown effect as well,
so it's great.
And you get two Death Traps.
I wonder how he's doing that.
That's on me.
That's on me, guys.
Yeah.
All the teasing on this stream.
And finally, before they play the walk-off music,
I think I could showcase...
Let's do Gregor's Lightning Square.
So if you notice,
Lilith's skill had like a slight cooldown.
This one scales with your build really well,
so the more you can cast core skills,
the more you get these iconic kind of lightning strike panels
shoot out from your character,
so you can imagine you can just go full Thunder God here
the whole time with your builds.
So, yeah, I think that's all I can showcase today,
but I appreciate the time.
No, thank you.
That was awesome.
Yeah, so again,
those are just like kind of a sneak peek
at just a handful of the powers.
Again, throughout the course of the PTR,
you'll get to experiment and engage with all of them,
and again, looking forward to the feedback
and just general notes
of how you incorporate into your builds
and what really excites you.
So I think that's pretty much the wrap-up
for all the content coming in Season 8
that persists beyond and within.
Yeah, all the Season 8 stuff
that will be available in PTR
for players to actually jump into.
We're still going to be talking about
a few more things
as we get closer to Season 8
with the launch of the actual season itself.
So, Derek, thank you so much
for walking us through everything.
And of course, with a new Season
and a new PTR,
we have a lot of changes
that are coming to classes,
specifically like the Rogue,
which...
We saw so many things in those.
We'll just skip the Rogue.
There's other classes to talk about.
Yeah, so Charles over here
is actually going to go through
all the class changes
that players will be able to experience
and test out during the PTR.
Yeah, of course.
I mean, there's tons of new bosses to fight,
so how are you going to fight them?
So let's talk about some class updates
that are coming.
First, I want to talk about some updates
that are going to affect all classes
in some way.
These are kind of a bit more generic updates.
So talking about ultimate scaling,
this is something that we introduced
in Season 7,
the current live season,
where as you get to rank 5
of the ultimate skills,
some of them had mechanics
that allowed you to crank up their damage
by building different stats, right?
So if you got more damage while fortified,
then your blood wave
is going to do more damage, for instance.
We think that's really cool.
It enabled a lot of very powerful builds.
A lot of very powerful builds.
And so we're looking at ensuring
that those don't really eclipse
every other option in the game.
We still love that those are powerful builds.
We love that you're playing them.
We don't want them to be the only option.
And so with that in mind,
we're looking at putting a cap on that scaling.
You can scale them up to 200% bonus damage,
which is still a lot.
You're still doing triple damage.
But we just want to make sure
it doesn't get completely out of control
with all the new stats
and some of the scaling coming in
from some of the seasonal powers
that could potentially lead those to be,
you know, crowding out other options of gameplay.
Additionally, we're looking at crowd control.
This is something I talked about
on our last Campfire Chat
about how we're really looking
at the moment-to-moment combat of our game.
You know, like, what are you doing, like,
like, one second to the next?
And one thing that came up a lot was
sometimes enemies just randomly get crowd controlled.
They randomly are frozen or stunned.
And a lot of this comes from some of the,
what we call incidental crowd control,
as in lucky hit crowd control effects
or anything that involves not like,
oh, I pressed a button, now they're stunned, right?
And we noticed, like, hey,
we got a lot of these effects across the game
in many different places.
And so we looked at really toning those down,
specifically in the generic spaces.
I know Fist of Fate is one of,
a very popular unique item right now
for many reasons.
One of them was that,
that kind of free crowd control.
But that's something that we think
wasn't really promoting the best
moment-to-moment combat
and most engaging flow.
So that particular affix has been changed
to lucky hit apply vulnerable.
But a lot of the other identity of Fist of Fate
is still there as well.
So it still has, you know,
wide ranges on things.
It still does random damage
and a lot of lucky hit chance as well.
Yeah, and this change really
puts the value of Frost Nova
and Ground Stomp
and it sort of makes those
more valuable and satisfying.
Right, yeah.
So if you really want to get
those kind of crowd control effects,
like, it's going to be
a build choice.
You're going to have to
consciously do it
and you're going to, like,
know when it's happening.
It's not just,
oh, they randomly got stunned
and, you know,
if they didn't get stunned,
maybe you got hit.
And that never felt good
when it was just kind of purely random.
Yeah.
Additionally, this is something
that the keen-eyed among you
might have spied
when we were looking
at some other stuff.
We've done a bit of a naming pass
on some of the damage over time effects.
This is no functional change.
This is just a naming thing
where we have things like
physical damage
and when it's physical damage
over time,
we call it bleeding.
And when it's poison,
we call it poisoning,
for instance.
We didn't previously have names
for shadow, lightning,
or cold damage over time.
We would just call it, like,
from shadow damage over time
affected enemies,
which was an absolute mouthful.
So we've got new common terms.
Shadow damage over time
will be called corrupting damage.
Lightning damage over time
is shocking damage.
And cold damage over time,
which we saw with
the wandering death chest beam,
is called frostbite damage.
So that's just a terminology thing.
It still relates
to those base damage types,
same as always.
It's just a terminology update.
Cleans up the tooltips.
Absolutely, yeah.
Alright, so let's get on
to some of the actual
class updates,
starting, oh,
we'll just go alphabetically
with the Barbarian.
Alright, so our focus
on Barbarian this season
is about,
primarily about
Barbarian's core fantasy
of being physical
and hitting enemies
with a big weapon, right?
In the past couple seasons,
a lot of the meta builds
around Barbarian
have focused around
things like earthquakes
or dust devils,
which are really cool
and fun,
but I think they,
we got some feedback
that, hey,
I don't really feel like
I'm hitting enemies
with my big weapon,
I'm just making
a tornado that hits them,
which is not maybe
fulfilling the fantasy
that you want
out of a Barbarian.
Your core skill
isn't the cool thing,
it's the thing
that the core skill spawns.
Right, right.
And that's,
it's cool that those exist,
but we want to make sure
we're also catering
to that, you know,
heavy hitter
kind of fantasy.
And so a lot of the updates
this season are focused
around that,
specifically updates
to double swing core skill
and the twin strikes unique
to make that a bit more impactful
to actually be hitting.
Whirlwind as well,
that's getting a buff
and a rework
with Gore's,
its unique Gore's
devastating grips.
And then the new unique
and legendary this season
really talk to Mighty Throw
in particular
and make that just like
the biggest hitting thing.
Let's take a look
at those uniques
and the unique
and legendary here.
So we've got the Bane
of Aja Den.
This is a unique glove item.
And it says that
every 12 seconds
your next Mighty Throw
is going to detonate
all of its pulses instantly.
You know,
normally Mighty Throw
like pulses over time.
It's going to do them
all at once
and deal massively
increased damage.
And that's going to
pair up very well
with the new legendary
aspect of delayed extinction,
which causes both Mighty Throw
and Steel Grasp
to gain multiplicative
bonus damage
rather than cooldown
from cooldown reduction.
So if you've got
cooldown reduction
on your gear
or on the Bane
of Aja Den,
for instance,
that's not going
to actually reduce
the cooldown.
It's going to be
a multiplicative scaler
for these skills.
So now you've got
a new problem to solve,
right?
You can't cast
these skills quite as often,
but when you do,
they're going to hit
super hard.
And so we've got
a video clip of it
just deleting a screen.
So you walk up
and they're all got.
One hit,
that's all it takes
because you've got
all these multipliers
on your one big hit.
But of course,
because it doesn't
benefit from cooldown reduction,
that cooldown is going
to be pretty much
locked at that 12 second mark.
And so you're going
to have to find
some other way
to kind of fill the gap
in there
and you've got
a new challenge
for your build to overcome.
I'm hoping to see
like Belial get decked
by this.
I think it is possible
that you're going to
melt some bosses
with some really big hits.
It's a great finishing move.
Oh yeah.
All right,
let's take a look
at the Druid.
So for the Druid,
I want to talk
a little bit about
one of the meta builds
right now
is revolts around Cataclysm
and kind of
snapshotting issues
that come up with that.
And so for those
of you who don't know
what snapshotting
basically means
is for Cataclysm,
which is one of their
ultimate skills
that has a duration.
So you press the button,
it summons a storm
around you that lasts
for some amount of time.
And if you get a lot
of that cooldown reduction
and you can cast Cataclysm
a second time
before the first one expires,
currently on the live game,
the second cast of Cataclysm
will keep all of the bonuses
and like bonus damage effects
or guaranteed overpowers
or whatever
that was affecting
the first one.
And that was definitely
not intended.
That is not how
we wanted that to work.
We didn't want bonuses
from one cast
kind of instance
to carry over
to the next cast.
Now this can only happen
in situations
where you get
that lot of cooldown,
but it was kind of
promoting this gameplay
where it's very
feast or famine.
If you successfully
kind of snapshot
all the buffs,
this build is insanely powerful.
And if you mess it up
or you don't get
the snapshot quite right,
you're actually really weak.
And that led to
unintuitive gameplay
and this really
big divide
between the best
and the optimal
and like kind of
the average normal case scenario.
So we're addressing that
where we don't really
want to promote that
between two different
cast snapshotting.
Yeah, we don't like
snapshotting in general.
Right, yeah.
The kind of snapshotting
where you are
persisting things
between different
cast instances
or equipping gear
and then unequipping it
to maintain a bonus.
Those are snapshotting things
that we don't think
promotes healthy gameplay.
It's unintuitive
in a lot of cases.
You need to read a guide
and follow an exact checklist
to do it.
That's not something
that we think
is good for the game.
There are some cases
where, you know,
with Cataclysm,
you know,
giving the bonus
to that whole
that first time
you cast it,
that it,
you might say
it's kind of snapshots
for the duration
of Cataclysm,
but that's intended
where it says
your next cast
does something.
That's what we want,
but we don't want
that to persist on
to multiple casts
or through
basically infinitely.
So that's one thing
that we're adjusting
on Druid,
but we're also looking
at promoting
other play styles
as well.
We think that build
is fun,
but there's other ways
to play Druid as well.
Specifically with Stoneburst,
that's the Earth Core skill,
it was kind of
a channeled skill,
which from a lot
of our channeled skills,
they are not allowed
to overpower,
but with Stoneburst
particularly,
we have reworked
one of its legendary items
to allow it to overpower
when you detonate it
at maximum size,
which is really cool
and opens up
some new build possibilities
for Stoneburst.
And finally,
I want to talk about
the new unique
Gathlin's Birthright.
This is a,
let's take a look
at it on screen here.
It's in a similar vein
to Tempest Roar
and Vassilius Prayer,
where it is a unique helm
that is very transformational,
but rather than talking
to werewolves
or werebear builds,
it's talking to
human form builds.
If you just,
you don't want to,
you don't want to embrace
the wilds quite as much,
you want to stay
in your human form,
Gathlin's Birthright
is going to be
the unique helm for you.
It says,
while you're in human form,
critically striking enemies
with your nature magic skills
will grant you
Anima of the Forest
for 10 seconds.
And when you get,
whenever you gain
Anima of the Forest,
you are infused
with bonus key passives,
Perfect Storm
and Earthenmite.
So if you have this
and you have
another key passive,
you can potentially
have up to three
key passives active
at once,
which is not something
we've ever done before
in Diablo 4.
That's nutty.
And I love that
it's on the helm,
so if you really want
to be a human druid,
which historically,
you know,
hasn't been as great
as a werewolf,
for example,
this is the helm for you.
Yeah,
this is exactly,
exactly that.
It's in a similar spot
as like,
hey,
this is build defining
in the way that
Tempest Roar is
for werewolves.
We want this to be
the build defining helm
for human form druids.
Additionally,
aspect of impending deluge
that empowers your storm strike,
which is probably
pretty useful
with this human form
nature magic build,
which will cause
your storm strike
to deal more
and also increase damage
that they take
from your other skills
for a time.
I think we've got
a picture of this,
or a video of this
in action,
where you've got
your druid,
it's got your,
you need 200 stacks
of Anima of the Force,
which sounds like a lot,
but it triggers on every hit,
so in most combat situations,
you actually stack it up
pretty quick,
and see,
once you get this online,
you're going to be empowered
with Earth and Might
and with Perfect Storm
and with Nature's Fury.
You have all of this power.
And the idea of three passes
going at once,
the key passes is crazy.
Yeah.
And the boss power
slapped on top of that, too.
Oh, yeah.
It is a lot
when you get this empowered state.
All right,
moving on to
one of my favorite classes,
the Necromancer.
So,
Necromancer was probably
the talk of the current season,
Season 7,
with Bloodwave.
I know we've mentioned it
a few times on stream.
Bloodwave,
really good.
We've talked about
how we're going to look
at ultimate scaling,
so maybe it won't scale up
with the bonus damage,
at least not to the
same level
that it had before.
We're going to put a cap on that.
We also just think
we generally overshot the mark
on the unique item,
the Kissimmee's Legacy,
which really, like,
you get this item
and suddenly you're a god.
It just had
so much power
in one spot.
And we like a bit more
of that progression
that Colin
was alluding to before
about that
zero-to-hero journey.
And when you have one item
that is,
you equip it
and it's over.
Like,
you're as powerful
as you ever need to be.
That really shortcuts
that journey
and really makes it feel
less satisfying
than we want.
So we're taking a look
at reducing the power
of that unique in particular,
as well as some other
adjustments to Bloodwave.
We do want Bloodwave
builds to still be powerful
and still be an option
if you like that playstyle.
We just don't want it
to be the S++ tier
that it was in the past.
Additionally,
we're taking a look
at Bloodlance.
This is a core skill
that has historically
been very good
in multi-target
kind of clearing out
pit runs
or dungeon situations.
But then you run up
into a boss,
which, hey,
we're fighting a lot
of bosses this season.
Yeah, we'll be.
And it suddenly falls
really flat
because its core mechanic
is about, like,
arcing damage
between enemies
and if there's only
one enemy,
what are you doing here?
Right?
So with this update
to Bloodlance,
it's going to still
maintain some of that fantasy
where it arcs
the damage between enemies,
but if you're hitting
a target who's already lanced,
it's going to do
a massive amount
more damage.
So it's much better
in single-target situations
and much more viable
for bossing.
And finally,
the new legendary
and unique for this season
talks to minions.
So let's take a look
at Sanguivar,
Blade of Zir,
the unique
two-handed sword.
So this weapon
will empower
your summons,
so your minions
and your army of the dead,
to affect enemies
with Vampiric Curse.
Now, for those of you
played back in Season 2,
Vampiric Curse
was a mechanic
that we introduced
in Season of Blood
where you affect enemies
with it,
and as you kill them,
you kind of collect
their soul.
And then you can
unleash these souls.
They kind of run out
from you and explode
in this really
satisfying moment.
And we put that on
a handful of
legendary aspects,
but now all of your
summons will affect
enemies with Vampiric Curse.
And you can unleash them
with Army of the Dead.
And when you do that,
the souls from
Vampiric Curse
and Army of the Dead
itself will deal
massively increased damage,
scaling with how many
souls you've collected.
It's huge.
I love Minion Necro.
It's like my favorite one.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, this is really cool
for Army of the Dead
and Minion Necro
to just really be
that impactful moment
of summoning
an army of skeletons
to just eviscerate
the enemies.
And additionally,
aspect of service
and sacrifice,
I love playing
with this one.
This one feels
so good to play.
Your skeleton warriors
explode on death,
dealing a massive chunk
of physical damage
to surrounding enemies.
And to help make sure
they die,
they lose 25% life
per second while in combat.
So you're going to be
needing to resummon
them quite often,
but when you do,
hey, it's good
because they're going
to be detonating
for this massive chunk
at the end.
And additionally,
while you're resummoning
all your warriors,
your mages are going
to be super tanky.
They're going to take
90% less damage
and deal massively
increased damage.
So you're going
to have your mages
up pretty much
all the time
and you're going
to be focusing
on resummoning
the warriors
to run in there
and explode
and do their damage
that way.
That's awesome.
It's a really clever way
to make it feel
like you're constantly
summoning
and you have your
back line of mages
just obliterating.
Yeah, it's great.
Let's take a look
at Sanguivar Blade of Zier
in action here.
Oh no, sorry,
this is actually
service and sacrifice.
So you've got
your skeleton warriors,
the skirmishers,
they run up there
and then here's
Blade of Zier, right?
You get all those
like skeleton warriors
running out
when you activate
Army of the Dead.
You just get the
normal ones
that are running around
but then they all
you unleash
a stream of them
straight from you
with the
Sanguivar.
Really impactful
ultimate skill there.
Yeah, Army of the Dead
is just so underutilized
so I'm so happy
to see it come back
into the fold.
It's great.
All right,
next up we've got
the one we've been
teasing for a bit.
Thank you, Ruben.
The Rogue.
Let's take a look
at the idea with Rogue.
So as you probably guessed,
the theme of Rogue
this season
is looking at
Trap builds,
right,
with both
Death Trap
and Poison Trap
in a way.
Historically,
Poison Trap
has been kind of
underrepresented.
Death Trap builds
have been quite popular,
pretty powerful
and a lot of fun
to play.
Poison Trap
kind of fell
by the wayside
a little bit.
It had a number
of issues
that we're looking
to address this season
to really promote
Poison Trap
as a viable
standalone build.
And what we're seeing
from Ruben
was the Scoundrel's
Leather rework.
Now this is a unique
chest item
that's been in the game
for a while.
It was about traps
in the past.
We've done a rework
this season
where when you cast
a trap,
or rather every 10 seconds
when you cast the trap,
you're going to get
a bonus Death Trap.
So you could cast
Poison Trap
or Caltrops
or Death Trap itself
and then you get
a second Death Trap.
And when you actually
cast the Death Trap
active button,
you're going to
kind of jump
or teleport
to that position
so you can just
instantly get
into the fray there.
Oh, that's cool.
Yeah, so rogues
are all about mobility
and jumping around
the battlefield
and doing that
kind of thing.
This is just another
tool in their arsenal
to really jump in,
put the Death Trap
down,
which groups up
some enemies
and then they're
ready for you
to slaughter there.
But let's take a look
at the new items
that talk to
Poison Trap
specifically.
The Bands of Icarus Rose,
these are unique gloves
that says your Poison Trap,
which normally has
a 9 second duration,
it's always going to do
its full damage
over 3 seconds instead.
So it's much shorter duration
but higher DPS.
And it's always going to
benefit from all
of its upgrades.
You know,
that enhancement
and those modifications,
you just get all of them.
You don't need to put
skill points in
and normally
the two choices
are mutually exclusive.
You get both
with these
and they're going to
be even more powerful.
Additionally,
Poison Trap
will now also
benefit from your
combo points
if you're using those.
It's going to have
no cooldown
during the Inner Sight
if you're using Inner Sight
and if you're using
Preparation,
its cooldown
is going to be reduced
by the Preparation Trigger.
So previously,
Poison Trap
didn't really interact
with any of these
three mechanics very well
and now it benefits
from whichever one you want.
That's so cool.
So it really makes it
more like a core skill,
something I can work
into my rotation.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, you're going to
be wanting to use this
very often
with this unique.
And then the aspect
of Contamination,
as many builds
that focus around
Poison on Rogue
often want to build
Critical Strike Damage
because that's really good
with the Poison Imbuement,
Poison Trap
now also can scale up
with some Critical Strike Chance.
So with Aspect of Contamination,
it unleashes a Poison Burst
when it detonates,
like kind of initial
upfront hit.
And then if that Burst
critically strikes,
which, you know,
if you're building
a lot of Crit Chance,
it probably will,
or if you hit a lot of enemies,
then you're going to deal
increased Poison Damage
for a duration,
which will of course
increase the rest
of the duration
of the Poison Trap.
And this is probably
my favorite clip here.
Let's get a clip
of this one.
Right?
So you apply Poison Trap,
which it's going
to throw two of them out.
And one of its upgrades
knocks down enemies.
And because it's increased,
it knocks them down
for quite a while.
And so they just
take a little nap
in your Poison Traps.
I don't recommend it,
but hey,
if they do,
they take a ton
of Poison Damage.
I love the knockdown animation
of this guy's enemy.
Yeah.
This guy just falls right down.
Just sit down.
Lay down, I guess.
His face is in it.
His face plants
and then succumbs
to the Poison.
It's awesome.
All right.
Moving on,
we've got our Sorceress.
So the Sorceress class
definitely is one
of the ones
currently on Season 7
that I think
didn't have
any of these
real big outlier builds
that we'd kind of
talked about.
Some of the highest highs
come from like
the Blood Necro
or the Druid
with the snapshotting
Cataclysm.
And I think
I definitely want
to acknowledge
that Sorceress
maybe didn't have
some of those
real outliers
this season
and they were
maybe felt like
they were a bit behind
of those.
So as we talked about
with other classes,
we're definitely looking
at bringing those
outlier builds
down a notch
to bring them
kind of back
to the norm
of some of the
other builds
so they're not
so far ahead.
But for Sorceress,
we're looking at
improving some of
the quality of life
and some of the
interactions between
some of their mechanics
like Crackling Energy,
Meteors and Meteorites
and making sure
they scale well
with the build.
Like Crackling Energy
will now have
the Shock skill tag
so if you're building up
damage for Shock skills
or some of the other
synergies there,
those now interact
with your Crackling Energy
and additionally
with Meteor and Meteorites
they're not going to be able
to scale with each other's
damage which helps
builds just be a bit
more cohesive
and feel more
robustly supported.
That being said,
I think where Sorceress
has been in Season 7
is in terms of
like its power progression
and the relative strength
of its builds
amongst each other
is more of the
closer to the ideal state
of where we envision
all classes ending up.
We recognize that
they are kind of
a bit lower
than other classes
in Season 7
but we're looking at
bringing them up
a little bit
with improved quality of life
and build options
and making sure
that some of the
outlier builds
that's really skewing
that perception
are being brought
to be
to
bring them close together
and create some more
harmony between the classes.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And I think this is something
that we're actively looking at
again to the point
of early in the season
if things aren't really
performing to
the level of our expectation
and it doesn't feel good
then those are things
that we're going to buff
and Sorceress is a great example
of like what we're going
to be really looking at.
Yeah.
And we want to do that
in ways that make
we don't just want to slap
on a 50x scaler
on Sorceress
we want to make sure
that the builds feel
cohesive and coherent
in a way that makes
a lot of sense.
And so that's what
all the bulk of our focus
is for Sorc
this season.
Specifically
I want to talk a little bit
about Ice Shards
that's what
the new Unique
is going to be
working with here.
Let's take a look
at the Unique
The Hail of Virglass.
This is a Unique Helm
that's going to empower
your Ice Shards
to spread out
rather than shoot
in kind of a straight line
that kind of rapid fire.
It's now going to be
a spread pattern.
You can hit more enemies
with it
and you get bonus shards
and you're going to be
dealing increased damage
for every time
an Ice Shard's
damages an enemy
and it's going to stack up.
So it takes a lot of stacks
you need to be
spamming Ice Shards
you need to be hitting a lot
but once you do
it unleashes a lot
of bonus damage.
And also
it just makes the skill
in my opinion
a lot more usable.
I like the spread pattern
a whole lot
unless you hit
wider screen
and you can kind of
like shotgun enemies
if you get nice
and close to them.
That's cool.
And Shivering Aspect
a new legendary aspect here
enemies are going to
take increased damage
based on how much
they're chilled
or staggering.
Now historically
some of the Frost Sorcs
or some of the other
builds that were heavy
on those crowd control effects
sometimes they really
struggled into bosses
which hey
bosses are the theme
of the season.
It's very appropriate.
So we're making sure
that some of these
new effects
that scale based
on the crowd control effects
also work against bosses.
So this will
kind of
take how much stagger
you've built up
on the boss
and also give you
a bonus damage
based on that.
So really being cognizant
of hey let's make sure
this works
in the situations
you want it to
and it's not
night and day
oh I'm clearing
trash mobs
and then I hit the boss
and you just feel
so different.
We want to make sure
that's a bit smoother
of an experience
between the two
ways of playing.
Alright let's take a look
at the hail of virglass
with these new
ice shards in action.
Right so they
fire out pretty quick
they fire out
in a nice spread
and you can clear
through whole packs
of skeletons
with a single cast here.
Multi shot.
Oh yeah.
Multi shot with ice shards.
Alright and moving on
to our final class here
the spirit born.
So the spirit born
was in a pretty good state
I mean similar to
to sorceress
where it didn't have
those crazy
overpowered builds
but we think it's
in a relatively
healthy spot
and we're just
looking at empowering
new build options
and making tighter
synergies between the
builds and giving you
some new tools
to play with.
With that in mind
we took a look
at rushing claw.
It's one of my
favorite skills
on the spirit born
but never really
found its way
into any of the
most popular builds
in the past couple
seasons since
spirit born was
released.
And we've updated
the two upgrade
choices to be
kind of transformative.
It's kind of a
if you pick one upgrade
the current one
rushing claws
has four charges
and so when you
use a charge
you kind of
quickly dash
through an enemy.
And so you have
four charges
you can spam it
four times
real quick.
The other upgrade
now has been
reworked where it
gains even more
charges.
It gains 12 charges
but using it
consumes all the
charges.
So really it
has just one
but for every
charge that it
consumes it deals
massively increased
damage and it
hits a wider area.
So now gaining
cooldown reduction
or gaining more
charges actually just
increases your damage
output and it
promotes a very
different play style
for this.
So you get kind of
an option.
You can choose the
original version
which is still very
powerful and very
cool or you can
choose the new
upgrade and kind of
spend all your
charges at once,
do a big kind of
damage cooldown
and then work on
building up those
charges again to
deal even more.
Additionally we've
looked at storm
feathers and
specifically how they
interact with the
new unique item
the sunbird's
gorget which I
think we've got a
picture of right
here.
So the sunbird's
gorget is a new
unique amulet.
This really works
to synergize with
the eagle and
jaguar builds.
So it says picking
up a storm feather
which you can create
in many different
ways.
will form a fire
storm around you
for 8 seconds
that deals fire
damage.
And every additional
storm feather that
you pick up is
going to intensify
this firestorm.
It's going to make
it grow in size
up to a maximum
and then it's going
to increase its
damage output.
For as many
storm feathers as
you can spawn
this firestorm is
going to get more
intense.
But it only lasts
for 8 seconds
so intensifying it
or picking up more
storm feathers
it's not going to
extend the duration.
So it's kind of
locked to that 8
second duration
and then it'll
reset.
So you really want
to collect as many
storm feathers as
possible in 8 seconds
and then it restarts.
And also this firestorm
is considered an eagle,
jaguar, and storm feather
skill.
So you've got lots of
options for how you
want to increase this
damage through your
other talent choices
or your itemization.
You've got lots of
options for how to
work this into a build
in either eagle or
jaguar or both.
And following up on the
theme with rushing
claw we've got the
new rip and tear
aspect where rushing
claw is going to
deal increased damage
and is empowered based
on how many charges
you had when you
cast it.
So if you're taking
the upgrade that
gives you 12 charges
it's probably always
going to be with 4
plus and so it's
going to strike an
additional time.
But if you're
choosing the option
where you spend each
charge as you go
it's going to go
through a bit of a
cycle here.
You're going to get
an additional strike
then it's going to
get a guaranteed crit
get a guaranteed
overpower and when
you just have one
charge left it's
going to give you
a nice chunky heal
to help keep you
in the fight.
Nice.
There's a ton of
versatility in there.
Yeah, yeah.
Lots of different
ways to play and
it works great with
either way that
rushing claw now
works.
Alright, let's take
a look at the
Sunbird's Gorget in
action here, right?
So you're moving
along, you're picking
up tons of these
feathers and the
firestorm around you
just grows in
intensity.
You've got lots of
different ways to
scale it up and it
provides a nice
kind of passive AoE
around you as you're
picking them up and
you're really going to
want to make sure
you're kind of
thinking about
exactly how your
character's moving to
make sure you're
picking up as many
of these storm
feathers as possible
to maximize your
damage output.
Alright, that's a
lot.
We got a lot of
new class content
coming for every
class.
We did get through
all of them.
But yeah, I'm
really looking forward
to seeing all the
new builds that
these empower, how
they modify old
existing builds, and
all the interesting
combinations that I'm
sure all of you
will test out on the
PTR and find out the
most absolutely
broken thing and let
me know about it.
Yes, please let us
know if you find
something absolutely
broken, which I'm
sure you will.
Thank you again,
Charles, for walking
us through all the
different class
changes.
Again, we do plan on
having patch notes
along with the blog
related to everything
tied to PTR.
So there's other
changes that we
didn't actually cover
often here.
That will be on
the Diablo4.com
immediately after the
stream.
So everyone can
actually check it
out, inspect it,
do their theory
crafting and
everything related to
that.
Of course, with PTR,
we kind of want to
know when PTR
actually begins.
PTR is starting
next Tuesday, and
this is, of course,
PTR on PC Battle
Net, so players
will be able to
jump in starting on
the 11th, and it
will run for a week
there.
I will note that
players actually will
be able to also
pre-download the
PTR the day prior,
so around Monday
afternoon here in
California.
Translate that
using some sort
of time tool.
That will be when
players will be able
to pre-download, so
it will be about a
day beforehand.
One thing to note
is, of course, the
boost vendor,
MRAC, will be
available, which
will be dancing in
town for everyone.
But one thing we
did want to note is
that the boost
themselves will be
available probably
two days after the
PTR actually begins.
The reason behind
this is actually a
little bit tied to
how Season 7
performed.
One thing we
allowed players to
do was immediately
boost the second
they got into PTR,
and we really
didn't get that
whole entire flow
as we were
kind of going
through.
Yeah, the
head hunt and
things like that.
So we also just
want to hear your
feedback on the
leveling process.
This is why we
run the PTR.
We really want to
hear your thoughts
on how the
sort of more
uniform leveling
feels, how the
legendary drop
rates feel.
so that is
really valuable
to us for
launching a
really awesome
Season 8
Return of the
Wild.
Yeah, and so
after a couple
days, MRAC
will be more
than happy to
take your
Paragon levels
to insane
numbers.
So PTR boost
will be available
just a couple
days after that.
One other thing
I do want to
note is we
will of course
have our
forums available
and online
for PTR.
That is the
best place to
actually provide
feedback.
Of course, we
do look in
other places
such as Reddit,
Discord, etc.
but I will
say the
forums is
kind of
we turn
them on
specifically
like a
PTR section
so please
put feedback
in there
because we
are constantly
checking in
there for
any notes
feedback from
players on
that end.
One other
note is
within the
PTR, you
guys may
see a term
called the
Reliquary
that may
just kind
of pop
up here
and there
and we
haven't talked
about the
Reliquary
nor will
the blog
later today
actually be
talking about
the Reliquary.
I will say
that you guys
will hear more
about the
Reliquary
before the
start of
Season 8
in itself
but for
right now
ignore it
turn a blind
eye
I don't
know
but it
is a
rework of
our Battle
Pass system
that we're
doing
we're trying
to
we've heard
a lot of
comments from
players related
to the Battle
Pass
trying to make
it a little
bit more
customizable
for people
especially
for rewards
that they're
looking for
so we'll
have a
detailed
breakdown
of what
the Reliquary
is before
Season 8
so looking
forward to
kind of
sharing that
before we
actually kick
off this
season
and I
know I
have a lot
I'm trying to
get through all my
stuff
I know
it's like
I'm hungry
the last thing
we do want to
talk about
is I've
gotten asked
a million
times about
this and I've
even seen it
in chat
and it's
related to
a roadmap
for Diablo
4 and I
will say
that we
are actively
working on
a roadmap
that we can
share with
you all
which is
great because
it gives
you and
everyone
an opportunity
to kind of
see more
of like the
future vision
of what's
coming for
Diablo 4
we do plan
on actually
having this
roadmap out
before season
8 so
we're really
excited to
share it
so as soon
as we
actually do
have that
available
we of course
you'll hear
it everywhere
we will be
on every single
microphone and
megaphone out
there showcasing
what the
roadmap is
and you've
probably seen
roadmap
if you're
curious like
what does
a roadmap
entail
you've probably
seen some
of our
fellow teams
here at
Blizzard such
as like
Diablo Immortal
or like
World of Warcraft
they've actually
posted these
more public
facing roadmaps
and that's
something that
we want to
do here
so that you
guys have
that ability
of being able
to see what's
coming up for
Diablo 4
and more
exciting news
related to it
so
I know we
have Q&A
we want to
jump into Q&A
here really
quickly
so if you
guys do have
any questions
or anything
of course
we have our
chat available
on the
Twitch link
for Diablo
so feel free
to jump in
and ask any
questions
I know we
always queue it up
with one question
specifically
and do we
have a
question
slide
here
there we
go
how does
party play
work with
lair bosses
we kind of
covered this
a little bit
but I don't
know if you
guys want to
go into
specifically
more details
on this
yeah I can
jump into
that
so when
you are
fighting
the lair
bosses
in a party
and the
horde
spawns
when you
open the
horde
we essentially
do a bonus
chance for
an extra
drop
based on
the amount
of party
play
players
party
play
so if
you're
in a
party
of four
and you
open up
that
horde
it's
going
to
guarantee
an
extra
unique
item
so it
scales
with
the
high
tech
super
high
tech
let's
see
this
is
from
skulm
tv
any
plans
to
place
a
blacksmith
or
vendor
near
the
boss
rooms
to
help
people
quickly
salvage
slash
clear
inventory
without
having
to
go
into
town
I
think
this
is
something
that
we
can
definitely
take
away
and
consider
especially
with
the
revamp
flow
that's
definitely
something
that's
interesting
one
thing
that
the
revamp
flow
does
I
will
touch
some
philosophy
here
is
we've
heard
a lot
of
feedback
that
it
feels
mandatory
to
play
some
of
these
bosses
in
a
party
just
because
chain
bossing
is
so
lucrative
and
we
do
expect
some
amount
of
the
chain
bossing
to
come
down
a
little
bit
because
a
lot
more
of
the
resources
are
being
consumed
when
opening
those
chests
so
it's
not
a
direct
answer
to
your
question
I
think
it's
an
interesting
idea
but
I
do
think
the
amount
of
chain
bossing
and
required
trips
and
flow
breaks
to
go
back
to
town
from
some
of
this
bossing
is
going
to
come
down
a
little
bit
especially
if you've
been playing
a ton
of
party
awesome
question
from
fan27
Q&A
or
sorry
he wrote
Diablo
Q&A
and I
just read
that out
loud
any
chance
we
have
to
redo
strongholds
and
waypoints
on
every
character
single
season
I
can
answer
that
one
too
yeah
this
is
something
I
definitely
experience
it's
always
a
big
pain
in
the
ass
where
it's
like
oh
there's
some
cool
bounty
or
apparition
incursion
but I
have to
go
get
the
waypoint
it's
something
the team
has
been
talking
about
there's
no
concrete
plans
today
which
I
know
is
disappointing
but
it's
something
we
know
is
a
problem
and
something
we
100%
want
to
tackle
in
the
near
future
awesome
jokums
says
this is
actually a
question
that
you know
we were
talking
about
that
might
actually
come
up
but
would
you
consider
adding
the
frog
from
Witch
Powers
in
Season 7
as a
permanent
companion
skill
for
Druids
and
at the
moment
I
can
say
we're
not
for
that
specifically
but
it
is
a
thing
that
I
think
we
didn't
really
clarify
in
regards
to
what
from
Season 7
is
for
sure
staying
over
I
will
say
the
Witch
Powers
are
something
that
aren't
carrying
over
to
the
future
seasons
but
one
thing
in
regards
to
the
Tree
of
Whispers
is
that
we
have
a
bunch
of
new
NPCs
there
we
redid
the
layout
there
that
is
made
that
as
a
hub
that
doesn't
feel
like
I'm
just
going
for
the
tree
and
have
to
immediately
leave
it's
made
it
as
an
all
encompassing
place
that
you
can
most
definitely
tap
into
from
that
end
I
can
speak
a bit
to
the
seasonal
powers
as we
said
a lot
of
those
Witchcraft
powers
are
specific
to
Season 7
that
is
true
they
are
not
necessarily
coming
back
in
Season 8
but we
do hear
that
feedback
I
think
they
got
a
really
positive
reception
a
lot
of
the
Poison
Frog
one
of
my
favorites
fire
bats
and
all
kinds
of
other
things
that
are
very
visually
flashy
and
just
a lot
of
fun
to
play
with
we
hear
that
and
definitely
helps
us
to
inform
making
future
content
in
the
past
we've
done
that
where
we've
taken
some
favorite
seasonal
mechanics
put them
on
items
to
return
I
can't
speak
to
any
particular
plans
but
just
know
that
we
hear
this
feedback
and
it
will
definitely
help
us
to
help
craft
content
in the
future
we
got a
lot
of
questions
related
to
PTR
because
I
know
as I
mentioned
this
is a
PC
Battle
Net
PTR
and
there
there's
a
few
people
like
Kim
from
Canada
and
I
can't
read
this
because
the
text
color
is
so
jarring
but
we've
gotten
a lot
of
questions
related
to
PTR
being
on
PC
Battle
net
asking
like
hey
is
there
any
plans
on
PC
Battle
Net
works
best
for
us
is
that
Battle
Net
is
a
platform
that
is
housed
here
at
Blizzard
and
is
the
processes
of
getting
builds
up
there
making
any
type
of
change
especially
for
PTR
where
we're
in
a
smaller
window
and
we
may
need
to
change
something
really
quickly
just
it
gives
us
more
flexibility
and
allows
us
to
be
able
to
change
those
things
really
smoothly
I
know
with
other
platforms
and
everything
there's
more
processes
involved
for
good
reason
because
they
have
more
checks
and
balances
everything
so
it
makes
a
little
bit
more
difficult
some
of
those
fast
iterations
that
we
may
need
with
PTR
so
in
the
foreseeable
future
right
now
we
see
PC
Battle
Net
as
being
the
home
for
PTR
when
we
end
up
testing
anything
question
from
my
computer
is
telling
me
to
update
it
has
been
telling
me
for
weeks
don't
hate
me
IT
Chris
mate
says
will
the
lair
bosses
have
resilience
slash
damage
reduction
that
the
world
bosses
have
to
ensure
that
they
just
don't
get
one
shot
too
fast
with
some
classes
or
build
trivial
I can't
talk
today
trivial
I can't
even
talk
I think
this is
a great
question
it's
something
we
talk
about
on
the
team
a
bunch
and
from
our
perspective
adding
something
like
resilience
would
sort
of
devalue
that
power
progression
we feel
like
it
disservices
that
zero
to
hero
once
Belial
was
really
hard
but
now
I've
gotten
so
strong
I
can
just
crush
him
that
said
we
do
think
that
the
level
of
one
shot
ing
bosses
that
has
been
happening
is
a
little
bit
too
much
there
isn't
enough
of
a
journey
to
get
a
point
where
I
can
just
stomp
on
Varshawn
or
I
can
stomp
on
the
pennant
and
knight
so
what
we
have
done
is
like
Derek
mentioned
earlier
in
the
stream
we've
massively
buffed
a lot
of
these
bosses
so
much
they
were
like
these
bosses
should
present
more
of
a
journey
to
getting
a
place
where
you
can
really
stomp
on
them
throughout
the
torment
tiers
even
Uber
Lilith
herself
has
been
or
I
don't
remember
what
we
actually
call
her
Echo
of
Lilith
has
seen
quite
a
buff
and
that
should
mean
that
journey
to
getting
a
place
where
you're
really
farming
some
of
these
bosses
is
a
lot
more
fulfilling
but
it's
longer
also
you're
not
just
walking
into
Torment
and
one
shot
and
that
ties
into
what
I
talked
about
with
some
of
the
outlier
builds
that
were
just
blood
wave
macro
prime
example
of
being
something
where
you get
one
item
and
then
suddenly
you
can
one
shot
everything
it's
really
not
it
doesn't
promote
the best
gameplay
it's
fun
for a
little
shot
everything
but
that's
something
we
think
it's
much
more
engaging
to
have
a
power
progression
and
as
you
get
more
powerful
and
more
gear
and
more
paragon
levels
you
do
get
more
powerful
and
it
becomes
easier
to
overcome
these
challenges
and
then
you
start
feeling
that
real
powerful
stuff
as
you
really
complete
your
build
yeah
and
I'll
also
say
like
I
think
part
boss
ladder
really
did
encourage
the
one
shot
behavior
right
like
if
you
have
to
pay
materials
to
fight
this
boss
why
would
you
ever
fight
the
boss
when
it's
actually
a
challenge
right
you
would
only
fight
it
when
it's
really
difficult
but
the
changes
that
we've
made
have
really
sort
of
you
know
in a
fun
way
I'm
hoping
this
plays
out
that
you
can
sort
of
maybe
get
a
cheeky
run
in
on
Varshan
when
maybe
he's
really
hard
but
you
get
a
really
would
definitely
resolve
it
but
within
season
eight
the
team
took
the
extra
opportunity
to
also
just
inject
new
mechanics
and
updated
mechanics
to
the
lair bosses
across
the board
to
introduce
that
hiked
challenge
but
in an
interesting
way
that's
just
more
fun
I guess
really
for us
to enjoy
we have
a question
related
to
I'm
going to
speed
through
a few
last
questions
here
Lilith
will
ever
make
an
entry
into
maybe
the
boss
slayer
system
or
anything
this
is
from
Ganon
North
yeah
I think
that's
something
that
we've
been
thinking
about
and
like
what's
the
right
place
and
what's
the
right
time
for
something
like
that
she's
in an
interesting
spot
now
where
she's
kind
of
like
the
pinnacle
of
the
season's
journey
a lot
of
times
and
that's
something
we
can
definitely
think
about
especially
with
this
revamped
flow
of being
able to
summon
overpower
give you
all
the
previous
bonuses
at
plus
charges
or
just
the
extra
cast
it's
just
the
extra
one
so
if
you're
casting
it
at
or
more
charges
it
only
hits
an
extra
time
it
does
not
get
guaranteed
crit
or
overpower
heal
you
it's
kind
of
either
progress
through
one
benefit
at
a
time
or
you
just
get
the
plus
if
you're
using
the
new
upgrade
I'm
going
to
do
two
quick
last
questions
I will
end
on
the
one
that
everyone's
asking
I see
it
in
chat
don't
worry
in
regards
to
I lost
it
there it
is
from
mid
central
vowel
at what
point
will you
start
maybe
potentially
removing
uniques
that have
proven
to be
not
that
useful
or
do
you
guys
feel
like
uniques
are
feeling
bloated
in
the
current
setup
I
think
actually
feel
like
we
don't
necessarily
have
enough
uniques
in
terms
of
speaking
to
every
skill
like
I
think
that's
something
that
you
see
with
the
poison
trap
and
you
see
with
ice
shards
that
is
sort
of
why
we
have
the
boss
ladder
to
give
you
more
deterministic
or
targeted
ways
to
find
some
of
the
uniques
you're
looking
for
this
lets
us
have
a
lot
of
different
uniques
but
things
that
you
have
to
target
the
other
thing
I'll
just
say
too
is
part
of
the
game
is
random
items
and
figuring
out
how
to
assemble
a
build
out
of
the
random
items
so
we
don't
want
to
get
a
place
where
I
log
into
Diablo
uniques
I
want
and
I'm
done
with
the
game
and
it's
this
linear
deterministic
track
through
getting
the
pieces
that
you
want
but
that
said
we're
always
listening
to
the
feedback
and
if
it
does
start
to
feel
like
I'm
constantly
sifting
through
things
I
don't
care
about
those
are
things
that
we
can
absolutely
take
a
look
at
yeah
and
I
think
on
the
design
side
when
we're
looking
at
unique
designs
I
think
there
are
still
some
spots
in
the
game
like
with
poison
trap
this
season
where
there
were
some
skills
or
some
play
styles
that
had
some
threads
there
but
it
wasn't
really
a
complete
and
cohesive
build
and
still
require
a bit
more
support
so
we're
still
going
to
be
looking
for
those
opportunities
to
support
builds
or
play
styles
that
we
think
are
interesting
and
fun
with
new
uniques
every
season
but
additionally
we are
also
taking
a look
at
the
catalog
of
uniques
we have
in
the
game
so
a
good
example
on
Rogue
again
is
the
Scoundrel's
Leather
this
season
that
was
an
item
that
was
sometimes
played
but
not
often
for
its
actual
unique
effect
for
some
of
its
affixes
actually
it
was
pretty
powerful
but
its
unique
effect
was
pretty
lackluster
and
so
we've
done
a
whole
rework
on
it
we
said
hey
what's
the
identity
of
this
well
it's
talking
to
death
trap
builds
that
wasn't
super
compelling
and
so
we
said
well
let's
scrap
that
existing
effect
and
how
can
we
better
support
that
let's
take
another
try
at
this
so
that's
one
way
that
we're
going
to
look
find
those
underused
uniques
that
really
don't
find
a
home
we're
going
to
constantly
be
reevaluating
them
and seeing
how
we can
plus
them
up
and
make
them
achieve
the
potential
and
fulfill
that
build
niche
that
they
were
intended
to
do
in
the
first
place
all right
I mean
I ended
with the
last
question
because
everyone's
asking
this
related
to
aspirational
content
is there
going to
be
are there
more
plans
for that
things
like
whether
it's
potential
leader
boards
to
more
like
endgame
type of
features
and stuff
do we
where are
we
in regards
to
some
of that
yeah
I'll
say
the
team
absolutely
this
is top
of
mind
and
something
that
we
absolutely
want
to
improve
in
terms
of
adding
more
milestones
for you
to
reach
more
satisfying
and
more
rewarding
milestones
and
celebrating
those
milestones
so
the
team
is
actively
looking
at
what
are
ways
we
can
level
up
some
of
the
aspirational
feel
of
the
game
I'll
also
say
just
in
season
eight
again
a lot
of
the
torment
tiers
and
bosses
have
really
been
leveled
up
a little
bit
more
aspirational
and
challenging
satisfying
to
overcome
we
really
think
season
seven
was
a
fun
candy
rush
and
it
was
a
sugar
rush
sort
of
like
the
smoothies
everyone's
been drinking
behind
scenes
not
everyone
only
the
important
people
behind
the
screen
it
got
delivered
midstream
Marcus
redeemed
yeah but
season seven
was really
fast and
we do
think
when the
game
reaches
that
state
if
we're
just
nothing
really
you have
to
work
towards
so
we
are
sort
of
taking
an
approach
again
with
some
of
the
balance
changes
to
make
some
of
the
game
feel
a little
bit
more
aspirational
and
it's
a
focus
for
our
team
going
forward
yeah
and
I
will
say
we've
had
conversations
about
this
I
feel
like
almost
weekly
Colin
and I
talk
about
it
a
whole
lot
I
know
there's
a lot
of
discussions
happening
and
a lot
of
people
thinking
about
that
specifically
from that
end
so
a
huge
shout out
and thanks
to you
guys
for
jumping
in
and to
Ruben
of course
for
jumping
into
the
build
and
running
through
everything
again
PTR
is going
to be
starting
next
Tuesday
you can
early
download
on
PC
Battle.net
starting
Monday
afternoon
California
time
and
we
will
have
a
blog
and
patch
notes
and
everything
available
for
people
to
check
out
immediately
after
this
stream
really
looking
forward
to
everyone
jumping
in
testing
out
the
new
boss
layer
system
of course
the
new
powers
that are
associated
with it
all the
class
changes
and all
the
quality
of life
stuff
that we
talked
about
in terms
of the
leveling
journey
as you're
going up
within
this new
season
so
really
looking
forward
to
everyone
jumping
in
please
make
sure
to
take
advantage
of
giving
us
your
feedback
on
the
forums
or
Reddit
Discord
other
places
we're
going
to
be
most
definitely
checking
out
starting
all
next
week
so
thank
you
guys
again
we have
March of
the
Goblins
which
is
currently
going on
in
Diablo 4
and we
have a
D2R
ladder
reset
tonight
so
if you're
a big
D2R
person
feel free
to jump
in
it's
always
a
fun
time
we
will
see
you
guys
in
the
PTR
next
week
and
really
appreciate
it
thanks
all
everyone